welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Voss in Rick and Morty season 4 episode
2 stealing a shy poopers crapper is
enough to make you the king of [ __ ] but
if we were to dive a deeper layer into
this potty humor what is the real reason
Rick is so sad at the end of this
episode well here to help you make
mountains out of turds is explained our
Rick and Morty after show with hot takes
about the hidden dark meanings of each
episode that are definitely they're
intended by the writers not externally
applied by over-analytical fanboys just
only perceptible cues be sure to
subscribe to our Rick's play in podcast
feed which broken to the top 40 of film
and TV podcasts last week guys so let's
get in the top 10 baby later this
episode I'm gonna sit down with some
insiders from the show to discuss this
episode but first we got to talk about
what I think is a deep dark truth for
this episode is hiding I think season 4
episode 2 the old man in the seat tells
us the truth about one of the
longest-running mysteries of the series
what happened to Rick's ex-wife Beth's
mother Diane now the episodes title is
the old man in the seat reference to
Ernest Hemingway's the old man in the
see about an elderly fisherman doggedly
battling a huge Marlin
similarly old man brick battles with
Tony a stranger who used his private
toilet like the Marlin of Hemingway's
novel Tony defiantly pushes back until
an odd mutual respect forms between the
two now there are some obvious thematic
parallels of companionship versus
isolation when it comes to Rick and Tony
but two moments of this episode stood
out to me when Rick oddly hesitates
first is when Tony reveals that his wife
recently died gonna hang look at a photo
of my wife while you'll kill me sure but
I'm doing her a favor she either has
terrible taste or she's trapped in a
marriage to a toilet thief she's dead
I don't mind joining her life has been
hollow since I lost her Rick then opens
a portal to an alternate reality in
which Tony's wife survived yeah that
Tony still stole Rick's toilet and so
Rick angrily snaps at Tony
don't use your dead wife as an excuse
later Tony ignores Rick's thread and
uses the toilet again telling Rick that
the two of them are the same you need
someone to give you permission to live
you know what shy ooping is Rick it's a
pointless bid for control you want to
take the one part of life that you truly
think is yours and you want to protect
it from a universe that takes whatever
it wants it took my wife it clearly took
something from you again
rick has a reaction
these words this time tony's implication
at the universe took something from Rick
this combined with Rick's anger at Tony
using a dead wife as an excuse suggests
to me that Rick like Tony had something
really dark go down with his wife Dianne
now the only time the series has shown
us any version of Dianne it was in a
false memory that Rick used to screw
over the Federation in the season 3
premiere if you remember in that big
scenario a bomb from another dimension
kills the Diana Beth
so reconvince the portal gun to move to
a new reality to live with them but
again it's all a lie but you can't alter
anything you want about a totally
fabricated origin story what there have
been other references to Rick's wife
have you been watching closely at the
end of the autoerotic assimilation
episode Beth says and I know I sound
like mom but I can't sacrifice this
whole family safety just because I'm
afraid to leave again that episode ends
pretty similarly to this one Rick alone
depressed camera pulling away from him
as he cries and one of the few other
times that Rick gets this emotional was
in the close Rick counters of the Rick
kind episode in which he'll Rick what
was actually even more TV remote pulls
up a few positive memories in Rick's
mind
among them are him making love with a
blonde woman whose face turns into an
alien mouth now other memories of Morty
as a baby come up and Rick tears up
which evil Rick / evil Morty calls out
as super at a character for Rick there's
any truth in the universe
it's that Rick's don't care about
Morty's yeah he's right I think Rick was
not crying at the memory of baby Morty
he's crying at the memory of this woman
who I think is his wife so what happened
to Diane I believe Rick's obsession with
science eroded his capacity for love
Rick has even admitted this in the Rick
potion number nine episode what people
call love is just a chemical reaction
that compels animals to breed it hits
hard Morty then it slowly fades leaving
you stranded in a failing marriage I did
it your parents are gonna do it break
the cycle Morty rise above focus on
science so of course Rick's marriage
failed but how exactly well there was
one more moment in this episode that
caught my eye when Rick projects Tony in
his own toilet heaven after he rips open
a bag of fluid in which Rick is doing
this to several other people all of
these people are living their wildest
meaningless dreams and leaving me out of
them people you refuse to kill Andrew
used to let into your life the woman in
the bag behind Rick has blonde hair
pretty similar to Beth's and pretty
similar to the woman in Rick's memory I
think that could be Rick's wife bagged
up suspended in a perpetual heavenly
state perhaps in the past Diane got so
fed up with Rick's pursuits that she
began to sabotage his work to keep him
home maybe as his memory implied his
work caused some freak mutation to take
over his wife in either case he would
probably be unable to kill her but loved
her enough to allow her to live in a
heaven of her own design now again we
could just interpret this episode as a
potty humor take on the old man in the
seat but I will remind you that the
protagonist of that story Santiago is an
old man who only in fleeting moments is
described as a married man
I'm gonna do my best Hemingway here I no
longer dream the storms nor of women nor
of great occurrences nor of great fish
nor fights nor contests to strength nor
of his wife yeah his wife II think she'd
get mentioned a few more times in this
he only dreamed the places now and of
the Lions on the beach the Lions on the
beach for shadows the final line of this
book in which the old man's long sleep
begins the fate of the old man's wife is
a mystery maybe she's dead maybe she
left him after his obsessive pursuit of
a great catch on the sea either way both
sound a lot like Rick's lonely isolation
but hey that's just my explanation in
this episode might be [ __ ] but it's
fun to think about right no you're a
Rick and Morty fan who wants to be fed
imagination not play along when they're
solved hey whatever your thoughts are
stick around because we're gonna dive
deeper into this toilet episode with
Rick and Morty insiders after a brief
message from our sponsors this episode
of Rick's Blane is brought to you by
helix sleep after a long night of
analyzing every single one of Rick's
pieces of excrement you kind of need a
good night's sleep right well to do that
just go to helix sleep calm slash Rick's
plane to take there two minutes sleep
quiz and they'll match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life whether
you're a side sleeper hot sleeper like a
plush or firm bed with helix there's no
more confusion and no more compromising
on an average mattress helix sleep was
awarded the number one best overall
mattress pick of 2019 by GQ and Wired
magazine they have a 10-year warranty
and you get to try it out for a hundred
nights risk-free Aleve
pick it up for you if you don't love it
but you will helix is offering up to
$200 off all mattress orders for our
listeners at helix sleep comm /r
explained that's helix HCl is sleep comm
/r explained for up to $200 off support
for explained also comes from manscaped
the best in men's below-the-belt
grooming manscaped offers precision
engineered tools for your family jewels
it's time to gear up and get yourself a
gift of shaving this holiday season I'm
talking about the manscape perfect
package 2.0 I get why Santa Claus lives
as far away from his South Pole as
possible because you know a fellow that
furries got to worry about snagging some
skin
that's why manscaped has redesigned the
electric trimmer their lawn mower 2.0
has proprietary advanced skin save
technology so this trimmer will old st.
Nick or old st. snag your nuts it's also
waterproof so you can use it in the
shower the lawn mower 2.0 comes inside
their perfect package 2.0 which makes
the perfect gift this holiday season
it's literally everything you need to
keep trimmed cut free and smell a nice
down there the manscape perfect package
2.0 includes the crop preserver and the
crop Reviver to keep your balls from
sweating smelling or sticking and these
products smell good they're manly scent
is attractive and will help set the mood
if you know what I mean get 20% off and
free shipping with the code are
explained at manscaped comm that's 20%
off with Free Shipping at manscape calm
and use the code Ricks planed
clean up your nuts and make Santa proud
this year and we're back to discuss Rick
and Morty's season 4 episode 2 the old
man in the seat and we freaking loved
last week's chat so we have our friends
back to the show
Rick and Morty Rider Abid gate how we
doing
and friend of the show comedian superfan
of Rick and Morty and extraverted pooper
this year and I'm wearing a new shirt
finally we were able to get you to do
this yeah shirts for once milestone well
let's dive right into the ship because I
bet you you were saying when we were
watching back the episode that like
Rick's whole shy pooper routine might be
like connected to something behind the
scenes the show oh just because yeah
because I think Dan is a shy pooper
because of all of his Instagram and
Twitter stuff that he seems to be like
he'll be on the toilet oh so you know I
you know he's on the toilet yeah he'll
do that stuff any while he's posting and
I think it's a way to like deal with his
shyness there you know and I just I
don't know I mean we're all shy when it
comes to pooping yeah I mean I I am I
mean I don't like to tell people if I'm
going to do that I just leave yeah like
I have people let them know I go like
about 4 p.m.
yeah I can alert somewhere you want to
take down intimidation of someone
imagine them on the toilet oh yeah yeah
that's the new imagine the audience in
their underwear is just imagine everyone
who scares you on the toilet that's
right that's right I get it you know
like you can call this episode just like
poop humor but like that like next to me
on a deep dark core cuz yeah when I'm
using bathroom I wanted to be on a far
remote side of the office I don't want
anyone else to know about it I wanted to
be like clean and just my own little
like like if I had a million dollars I
could live in a shitty apartment but I
just want that bathroom to be like an
oasis like a grill to be made out of
gold yes
you spend all your money just on the
tour are your opinions of places
elevated by their bathrooms or ordi
elevated
escalator was the right word whatever it
means less place has a really nice
bathroom it could be the worst plate
like a restaurant could be a terrible
restaurant but if they have a really
clean shiny crisp bathroom this place is
great five stars yeah
food poisoning was actually pleasant
because I had a bathroom to go into
right away yeah it's got like an ocean
feel to it like everything she'll just
like birds really scrub your hands clean
they have the three seashells and I like
that you guys know what I'm talking
about we all had this like same dream
for what we want our bathroom explains
to me so like I think this is an episode
that you could write off and I think
people who don't watch or like Rick and
Morty like oh it's like just [ __ ] humor
it's like that kind of humor but like no
I think you know ah scream producer Zack
was saying when we were chatting about
this episode that you can do a dumb
concept really smart or you can do a
smart concept really dumb and I think
this is an example of the of the former
of like what seems just like a dumb
topic but like they do in a really smart
human way like I mean how does Rick and
Morty how is it able to transcend that
that just kind of lowbrow humor but do
it in this smart well in a way because
if you think about it they never had
Danny Tanner going off to take a [ __ ] I
never had Steve Urkel and it's like if
they did they would make it really
stupid but in this when you're imagining
Rick doing it it's a very interesting
like parallel into it like there's a big
story there yeah and that's probably
that's pretty amazing
yeah there's that whole thing in like
Hitchcock's Psycho where it was the
first movie to show a toilet on screen
and it blew everyone's minds because up
until avoid constant movies they never
showed the inside of a bathroom they
just pretended like no one poops I feel
like I've heard that I mean I could see
back then people running out of the
theaters like vomiting yeah yeah they
see a toilet right that's worse than the
shower scene their bathrooms they open
the door they're like we have one two
there's one in our house we've never
known what it was born Rockies
everywhere oh my god he does that to
stars they're just like us aren't they
they are I do love that like yeah
imagining what would Rick's ideal
bathroom be if he is a Shia poo pourri
but even if he weren't a sh ty poop
review had the ability to build a world
just for a toilet like yeah this it's
it's interesting to see the design of
this world like it seems like a Pandora
like some kind of like ideal heaven like
that's his heaven where where he goes in
the bag and he takes a global thing
that's where he goes it's just being
able to sit on a toilet and industry
drugs and toilets yeah now I'll say that
this episode reminded me a lot of pickle
Rick where it seems like this kind of
like just dumb idea that's just a
throwaway thing but it ends with this
profound wise voice actor whose lectures
Rick on his own depression and it ends
in kind of this dark place yeah do you
think Rick will ever get better like is
he on a trajectory towards well health I
hope not for the show's sake yeah
because I think it's more interesting
that he's stuck I mean I hate to say
that but that is the kicker of this
episode yeah seeing Rick it is worse
mm-hmm you know and I don't know if he
can get better yeah I think he's got his
since like a serious problem he
definitely has the show exists if he
gets better
doesn't it just become something like
the more the most like the happiest tea
I've ever seen him on the show was him
wading through the weeds to get to the
toilet the way he looked so content and
so like like he wasn't this is like a
brilliant genius we've established in
this show whose mind is taking about a
million things every second and he was
so singularly focused on just going to
the bathroom and he was like at ease it
was like the most relaxed who's ever
I've ever seen him animated on that show
so it's interesting to think like you
get that in the snippet and then he
refers back to the river we know yeah
yeah yeah you get a moment of clarity
and and sweetness and but then it's just
muddled in all this dark I mean it's
sort of like if if well when Tony and
Angela got together the show is over
mm-hmm you're like ah there's nothing to
fight for now right or moonlighting you
know when they got married you're like
where's the fun now yeah so they'd be
like if Rick just became happy yeah
that's true I mean its fatty that's like
a good point this planet is his one
sanctuary this is like the one time we
see him where it's like oh this can just
be Rick in a zenful state and then by
the end of the episode that's taken from
him too and his way of like getting back
revenge against his toilet thief is with
this like mockery of his like isolation
and lonely yeah for most people it would
be like in Winnie the Pooh is thinking
spot is yeah you know for most people
but in Rick's twisted - where he shits
right it's his Fortress of Solitude
there you go that's another man was
[ __ ] I mean Superman must have giant
horrible [ __ ] destroying every toilet
you know what if we can create stomach
lasers to just mash it up rise it so
there's no evidence we're not eating
today I know we're very squeamish and
this episode should have repulsed us
like I normally can't handle this type
of humour at all but it was like we said
handled in such an intelligent way and
there was such moments of compassion and
weird can that human connection that
human an alien connection that I was
able to kind of almost forget what the
main gimmick of the episode was and just
enjoy the jokes and the performances so
I mean that's
I can't think of a hired moment to say
like yeah well stop by what should have
been the grossest episode of the show me
too I can't handle that stuff I'll get
like I'll start to gag yeah I'll never
watch Solow Sal oh you guys know that
movie all right well you it's better you
don't we're just gonna know it's a good
movie but I'll never watch it it's a
good movie well it's Pier Paolo Pasolini
but it's like there's a scene in it like
pink flamingos like that kind of oh yeah
there that that was what you guys
understand yes same thing we'll never
watch it one of the things that caught
my eye in the first part of this episode
I talked about was the idea that like
it's the fact that Tony the toilet thief
is a widower he has a dead wife that
gives Rick point of pause and hesitation
and kind of sees a connection with him
because one of the longest-running
mysteries on the show is we don't know
what's to deal with Rick's wife is she
dead is he a widow or two is it just his
ex-wife and they're estranged or
divorced Rick has mentioned in past
episodes how his marriage failed and
didn't work out but I you know I had the
theory that like this is really about
him and his ex-wife do you think that
there might be something here with like
his home planet and it being connected
to his ex-wife Diana you asking me yeah
I well I said this earlier I have this
theory because you brought that up which
I totally forgot that they sort of they
hint at it before that maybe this planet
is like where they spent their honeymoon
because like when you know she died this
is all he has left of her yeah so it's
like to him that's a special place yeah
and it's so close to his heart that he
has to take a [ __ ] there yeah like no
there there's probably like specific
reasons why this planet is designed the
way it is like why does it put a Rick in
this trance is it just aesthetics or
does it have like some kind of
meaningful there's something it's
beautiful so it seems weird yeah what is
that weird crystal that's in the archway
like is that the power see I'm thinking
maybe that's the diamond band his
engagement ring that he gave because it
looks like it's a setting in
but it's got this diamond shape to it oh
yeah it looks at his engagement ring
every what if they have to change the
story lines cuz we figured it out I hope
that just liking so then I want to be
alright story by credit will be fine
yeah sure just give us a credit and
guild credits tell my parents that I'm
not a complete failure a phone call to
my parents actually suffice I mean it's
not rocket science but I mean in in our
minds and how we like the show that is a
very interesting concept yeah you know
it makes a lot of sense yeah I owing
Rick I hope that we do get like more
information about Diane cuz like these
clues have been interesting and I think
like it wouldn't be contrary to Rick's
character to find out more of why his
marriage failed and why he's so
skeptical of Beth in Jerry's marriage we
all know it's the drinking right well I
mean that's clearly the problem yeah
yeah cuz he's yeah the guy is super
cynical in general he doesn't believe in
anything other than science did whatever
happened yeah oh that's a good point
yeah there's some theory see he was
normal yeah yeah like one of the things
I've heard is that Rick's whole
exploration of the multiverse his portal
gun he invented after his marriage fell
apart or that happened at the same time
right
he had to get away from his problems by
jumping through a port that would be an
interesting like if although he is the
protagonist just based on the point of
view of the show he has kind of a
supervillain origin of like what if he
was just a normal scientist that had an
event that triggered this like breaking
him that made him kind of diabolical
yeah yeah yeah I mean cuz the obvious
thing is that alcohol ruin I mean that's
more of an obvious yeah I mean that
probably is what happened he's probably
really deep and disturbing well
hopefully we see more of that deep in
just disturbing history but thank you so
much
youtube for coming on the show again to
chat about this well thanks for having
me yes and I have a good time here so
thanks for having me back we have a
great time to follow Abed on Twitter at
Abed G you can follow Tommy Bechtold on
Twitter at Tommy Beck told and be sure
if you haven't already to subscribe to
our Rick's plane podcast meat so you can
get early access to audio versions of
all this stuff and you can follow me at
ei vas on social and pollen rocks
social setting rock stars and make sure
to subscribe to new rockstars on Twitter
on YouTube as well to just be able to
see everything that we're doing and keep
an eye out for our breakdown of all the
missing animation jokes that you might
have overlooked this episode and we'll
be back next week with our analysis of
episode 3 thanks for watching guys and
we leave you with one of our favorite
jokes from this episode what how are you
doing parenting that's not how I did it
yeah where's your daughter
hey you're right join Isis
[Music]